but I was on the side and I'm looking at
these hooligans
yeah and it was in the middle of one of
their sets and and was named Ian what's
his name Ivan Ivan and he goes oh Sulu
cute over there and there's a kid in the
hot tub he was bringing the child to me
and this child and the child crowd surfs
to the front can't be more in five six
years old little Latino innocent child
eyes big bright like a Disney
show right and she's looking around and
he goes what's your name I don't know I
is whatever name is he goes do you like
do you have a curse what today you got a
curse and I just remember loose kidney
goes he goes are you ready to say this
any she said she looks at to a sea of
white human beings going and the kid was
horrified and that's what I realized
what did we get her
[Music]
this is true Manju Hatfield
I love fumet achoo james
hetfield it's the price the bonfire
comments at radio sirius XM 95 I'm Dan
Soder that's me Jay oakerson and his new
special available April 5th were every
Ustream albums live from Portland Jim
brewer on the show just having a
time
thank you drinking coffee you know
crown and playing Metallica fu-manchu's
it's just you didn't have you know
Brahman when they cut the hair I was a
little I was thrown at first a little
bit but then with it I just remember
Allison chains on there unplugged the
bassist had on his guitar friends don't
let friends get haircuts cuz cuz
Metallica was in the audience well they
made you deal with a lot at once they
cut their hair and then started making
three and a half four minute rock songs
yes and that was a that was a lot you
were like oh you start getting worried
you like is about to become Bon Jovi
like were they they went from like I
thought they were so cool to like music
from my mom yeah and like I was worried
that Metallica was gonna pull this in
some way you know Guns and Roses got out
of the game quick enough they didn't
have time to get old and change their
music really together and here we go
she's gonna be the change but they they
hung in there man and the music solid
and they every album they put out you're
like they still got it it's great
every time I remember getting Death
Magnetic early and I like super except
that's the last time it was like a CD
because everything after that was like
download but I remember getting Vic
Garcia my old roommate got me Death
Magnetic from a guy new at Warner
Brothers and I remember like listening
to it me like this just awesome
I loved it give it to De Rosa still cool
man there's I love the new album yeah
more than to me it's the greatest rock
album in 30 years okay Metallica yeah
greatest rock album and third you went
on the road with them yeah you just got
off the road with them just get off
through it awesome you also do a
Lars which is one of my sweet
those are one of those impressions where
I'm like how do I get him to do long
it's easy I'm it's it's he was
the one that helped me through this it
dude
he first of all the whole thing happened
where I got a text from Hetfield last
March yeah anyway and James is always
when they asked me do thinks he's very
vague okay so he's in Europe touring
anyway hey would you be interested in
doing some type of tour with us and I
and I immediately
I probably geeked out lutar oh dude I'll
kill you anyway
don't get excited it's not really
stand-up it's it's it's more of
something else and I haven't talked the
rest of the band okay two weeks later he
sends me ideas and the ideas are
blasting t-shirts into the crowd it's
I'm not off board yet t-shirt going
continue maybe there's a hardwired Harry
that roams the crowd or in the parking
lot oh god you're a mascot it's a first
suit here's the thing very breathable
very excited you're wearing a burlap
head we're about to unveil the ma'am the
magadhan Metallica mascot you're gonna
be inside yeah you're that golf cart guy
that drives what everyone you know it's
the ball at you so and he's throwing
these ideas that so I throw him ideas
and I don't hear from him yeah and may
comes now it's May and I'm at a gig and
I get a call from his manager hey man
and this is Marc are you around this
Sunday yeah whoo yeah man fact I'm alone
in New Jersey where I'll come to your
house and we're gonna come a house I
always imagined Metallica like
helicopters in like anyone that they
were like it was sort of like that what
even telling this is him reaching out to
you and saying like don't get excited
there's so many like comedians and just
people in the world who view you aren't
on that level to say like is a Jim
Breuer just texted me and then
you have a thing where you got your I
reached out he goes James probably busy
he's probably get back to me or whatever
against Yuri like oh what yeah dude
I'll talk to you what you want to talk
to me I'll call you right now I love you
there's 20 people you walk by they're
like really good talking line clear jeez
I text before the show I tensed up like
a prairie dog here in a hawk
screen when I heard Jim laughing with
Lou down the hall I was like it's
Jim Breuer I've never met him I
was like damn it's just like one of
those things where it's like yeah like
Jays look at me like pull it
together dude okay and so this guy Mark
comes to my house and I got I got home I
I got all my ideas lined up I got
everything a whole notepad I've got all
these different so if he doesn't like
this idea I got five other ones that are
gonna work yeah and he he lives a cage
every time yeah I'm in town but uh I'm
just thrown off that he's at my house in
the middle of nowhere New Jersey
yeah I know he lives in San Fran like
what is he doing here so he goes in my
kitchen and he opens up his laptop
computer and he opens like okay so we
start in September in Madison Wisconsin
and then we go off we go all the way to
March and it's basically like seven days
and I know you do a residency and
there's only one date at the Paramount
that you'd have to change and I don't
know if you talked with your wife Dee
but art are you into this that's so
funny
and I went well yeah he went great shots
it he goes we're announcing this
tomorrow and Stern and Rolling Stone and
we have your name in it and egos we'll
worry about developing what the show is
and and you know I'll talk the agent
will figure out fine
okay I can even think the and that's the
way they talk about government on the
news it's been handled there is no more
paramount and you are also the leader of
three hundred and thirty thousand people
and that's how and I I racked my brain
trying to figure it out what is the
first day of showing up for Metallica
school like we're done so here's the
thing I show up no first of all before
it even went down they fly me to like
Switzerland yeah - they are
Metalocalypse to see what the stage
looks like we have a this is where
something any comic could have handled
with a simple cell phone picture got you
it's like they tell us because you want
to come soon stupid or soundcheck like
I'll just trust you guys have a
microphone that works worst-case
scenario I'll ask you to pump the mic
volume yeah you want to see if your
shirts blend in with the backdrop to
money that's weird budget mr. Borelli
going to bring you to the Metallica
facility in the Swiss Alps it's where
they all train this is Lars at a pool
just running
he's got nodes all over I'm just ticking
mechanics James is being flush out with
fresh sheep's blood oh that's wrong
he'll whatever he bases he destroys a
hero is hitting 1,300 pounds of pressure
on each string so they so they take you
to Switzerland just to show you
the stage and meet all production yeah
[Laughter]
that isn't in a mall what am I
to you when I joined the first thing the
first show I did with corn at all huh
was it a small place in North Carolina
they called the ballroom blitz tour so
it was like thousand-seat places maybe a
little bit somewhere like a couple
thousand but for the most part was small
this is a small one it was the second
day on tour I joined the second day when
I get there the opening band is on who
you know as you know I ended up opening
my comedy son yeah yeah yeah and these
amazing gut but they won't stage I had
am a lead singer is a great frontman
he's bleeding actively on stage in the
you know I didn't know their music
before and they're they're going for it
and I'm so intimidating they go you know
you just go up in between them while
they sit up for corn I go I don't I
don't think it's gonna work go home your
mom and then I went on and it just went
that particular show my buddy John who's
in the military
yes stationed out there he just happened
to be able to go with and something
about just having a friend there also is
like I'm gonna go give it a whirl dude
you're almost like I'll play to you if
no one's paying attention like we'll
laugh at how much this just sucks but I
was a bit nervous it but you do you
walk in and everyone even dude members
of corn I'd be like I'm Jay I'm the
comic who's uh over the show goes we
have a comic now
yes yes Switzerland and it's the whole
as this basically where the whole tour
is learning how to build and take no no
no they're in the mill the tour this is
one the last shows okay so this is
they're gonna come off this rest for a
little bit and go back on with you right
Jan live in on the road yeah
break still rights like they go out for
a stretch yes but this is the end of
their tour and there's only two dates
left yeah
so I fly out there the day of ice at the
hotel at 9:00 in the morning they picked
me up at to bring me to the arena they
show me the stage yeah okay change
something if there could be candles yeah
here like you're adding you like this
you guys ever thought that that light
that lever probably be better over there
be nice if there were screens of people
could see me yes yes smart I said it's
all I need is a majors in the end this
is just a real set quick sidebar what
I've noticed from the ship rocked story
and the Metallica thing is like you're
like a MacGyver with performance where
you know how to just quick fix it where
you go drop it
we're just gonna improv situations they
know a comics coming on these things
yeah but nobody there no Scott the first
day that was the question that threw me
for a major loop they go you want to
give me your microphone he's like I'll
set it up for you before the show I want
what do you want to do what your
microphone do you don't your comedian
write this basically like musicians like
guitars travel with their guitar
this questions never come up in 18 years
of colossal no one's ever asked me if I
had my microphone please start googling
custom microphones because I want to
start showing up to have sold helium's
going like and go like this can you plug
man what's up Huntsville Alabama golden
fist I go there's Delilah
[Music]
that's gonna really rip in this room I'm
gonna take this with me to my hotel and
I'm totally down with that I trust I can
leave this here overnight
yeah you guys have a lockbox like your
BB King but that's the thing
right they want you to have some sort of
like answers for what you need yeah I I
said just a scream would be great and
then I watched the show and like all
right well would we all right we'll see
you back in the States
and then if now before before I leave
someone goes hey man Laura's in the food
room and you must talk to you
he's got 15 minutes what okay so I go in
there any site so he's eating so
basically why we hurried you is because
you're able to read a crowd and just
this is your thing just do what
you want all right well what that's yeah
I come in this is why I came cilinder
craft service Rocklin ideas just
run them by me and then I still is
really uneasy I don't know what and
people like your opening like I'm not
opening yeah I'm host emcee of their
opening whatever it's called the the
lighten up tour I did the corner I'm not
opening you're not doing a it's
Jim Breuer and it's 45 minute comedy set
yeah so now it's right it's about a
month before the show goes and I'm
stressing out yeah yeah you got a
big thing dude I reached out to
Jay
I'm calling Bilborough I'm like hey you
want to come join me on stage
I'm not the only one going down you're
all going down with me call a guy
and he awful in the
beginning spot did you open
Christina opening can you pull up
you pull up my calendar my enchants on
the screen the show Mike help after Jim
texted me yeah I have Metallica date
listen every dude you got the uniform
before you got hired at the job you're
just wearing the shirt and you're like
here we go
Papa John's gonna call I don't like
minions so I called Jim I came in you
available to like I don't know what I'm
doing I think I said I don't know what
I'm doing yeah I don't know what I'm
doing
yeah and then also I flew out I flew out
pretended I had a gig in San Francisco
knowing Lars was there for a couple days
more now I talked to Jay I talked to
James I'm friends with James yeah but
James is always kind of a he's like I
don't know just kind of I don't know you
know you do your thing it's not helping
me that's great rocks rock star Vega
isms it's a theater and around
okay so i sat with Lars I find Lars I go
to his house he's like why you here I
[Laughter]
have a gig out here and I went you know
what I really don't I want to wrap my
head I'm what you see and he see he's
laying down in a chair like his legs are
dangling over and he goes like this he
goes and and we could see the entire San
Francisco Bay it's a communities in
Tiburon and yes and he goes well not
anymore
he goes that's why had cousins
knowledge that house does an existing
well into that house had a great time
there I can't wait got good stories
there he goes
here's the deal first of all you're
writing bits and creating things that
are for like 15,000 people trust me when
I say you lucky maybe 800 maybe a
thousand people
being arena when you're up there so you
gotta think nobody's gonna be in there
that's number one number two you gotta
remember tell them why you here
because you know the band you know me
you know James you know stories tell
them stories the times you worked with
us but the most important things you
don't have to be funny as you go down
your name Jim Breuer know what okay okay
I don't have to be funny like it just
tell stories and just I trust you
I've seen you going to a room and you
can work the room you know the situation
and you just go with it it's
it's brilliant just you can do
that in front of our crowd he goes weak
at bands nobody goes see them it's a bum
for the band's bum for us so why not
give the crowd a fan experience that's
that's what we're looking for and I want
okay yeah all right and I planned this
whole thing for Madison
Wisconsin yeah and it was on I got a DJ
yeah a comedian that I can banter with
and he's gonna play songs and even that
guy came to my house and he's like he's
a punk rocker he doesn't know rock and
metal and he goes here's the songs I got
and every song every one in that
audience is Jim Breuer yeah they are
married their kids they grew up metallic
in 86 maybe some them loved give me if
you will give me five give it and that's
where they started but still those
people and not into none of the mirror
to that play old Van Halen David Lee
Roth not Van Halen
scorpions play play maybe a
little bit Pantera maybe you wanted to
not a lot of them they don't get you
crazy don't get crazy
play play what you hear now yeah on
Ozzy's boneyard and that crowd be happy
and I got
stories so I'll tell a story and go you
know one time when I met Asiata play and
a boom you play play
hey this hat my girlfriend and it's okay
so we're set boom boom boom and we found
the first show I walk out six o'clock I
shoot I learned everything after the
first show that's good I got okay I've
got Madison Wisconsin I've got the star
star player from there from there
college football team University of
Wisconsin goal pitchers yes yeah so I
got the Badgers Badgers were on her back
the Badgers quarterback I've got I'm
gonna run up on top give tickets away oh
yeah I'm gonna every 15 minutes I have
something scheduled you're dusting them
well first 15 minutes I go up hey how
you doing has maybe like 5,000 people in
the arena it's six o'clock really early
lars talent i bet six o'clock you really
feel like hard-wired Harry yeah right
through it now now I gotta run to the
top and I don't have a security guard oh
boy and I don't know how to get to the
top and the lights they can't find me
and so the guys on stage like Jeremiah
it's a disaster
round they said Metallica they're
insistent that Metallica goes up at 8:30
and Metallica Lars is insistent I stay
on stage until Metallica comes out
because Metallica is big Jim Breuer fan
and they want all Metallica fans to
start following Jim Breuer so that's the
part where I'm like wow thank you thank
you thank you okay 8:20 I go backstage
they go are they still going up at 8:30
100% great 8:25 I go on stage I get the
okay this section I think you're better
than this section you guys do the
hokey-pokey you jump up and down you're
allowed to name you say bah bah bah and
they're
and the guy goes stretch and I looked at
what oh okay okay okay okay
I did ten more minutes and now the
crowds getting a little tired yeah they
go like all right dude and I'm about to
get off and again
they're not ready like waka at 8:40
8:45 and now I'm getting the bottom the
bottom teeth yeah it's turning hard down
Jim Breuer teeth are going and I'm
getting a lot of this you get the
off the stage
three hours of anybody though I had the
t-shirt cannons they're not working so I
run out it's not five people it's it's
sections so just 114 now so at one point
the funniest part was I had the DJ on
stage and he's wearing glasses and can't
see what the he's doing he calls me
he calls me over on stage people booing
that told me get the off the stage
and I went oh man Metallica's
management's there everyone's
everybody's there watching the big star
for some reason cliff Burton's family's
whole super disappointed to them and oh
all of a sudden they say okay they're
they're ready it's 855 yeah but that
25 minutes they go up I go
backstage and I go oh my god
but my attitude is always like okay
let's tomorrow night we're gonna kick
their ass okay cuz in my life me and you
were the same I know we're being you are
I'm taking a detective shower in the
public shower with it just
running up with my hand against the wall
like not me I'm
I'm taking the old tags off my bag to
get ready to put the ones to go home
with well it was a failed experiment
look everything we could write we tried
that one night didn't work out the guy
was with on stage what you swear to God
Joseph we got a stage like dude we can't
do this I'm packing my bags we
I'm out I'm the whole I say did
let's let's regroup we know it works
with note the next night it was like
okay no I'm not going up to 7:30 yeah
yes you go out at 7:00 start playing
songs me going up in the crowd
you're going up in the crap I'm gonna go
up talk as long as I can with the
audience talk as months ago when I'm
done with that you are then gonna give
ticket giveaways you're gonna go up on
top you go way up there after that we're
gonna play a trivia game with the crowd
and do that we're gonna do a game show
I'm gonna bring couple knuckleheads up
and hopefully they get booed the
off the stage it'll be the most
entertaining thing in the world for the
crowd and that's by spy night two and
three I found a rhythm like it becomes
how easily and then when it comes every
day is just like Oh Stefan do my thing
real quick and then I get to sit and
watch metallic all night Jim well I'm
not kidding you by this second leg and
there was a part of me and I think only
you can understand this Jay I don't know
maybe you two do not know that's fine I
get it no maybe you two I'm green in
this pile of Metallica like let's say I
wasn't opening for him yeah I'd be in
the crowd banging my head so hard that
it would hurt the next day when I'm home
alone and I reached a point on never
forget this is a game changer for me so
the crowd is done I mean I'm done with
my set and I'm not getting booed I'm not
getting no go yourself go home die
get cancer I'm not getting those tweets
anymore from get from night two on it
was like I do it I get it yeah it's fun
so now there's this Korean guy and he's
hangout every song I don't know what
happened I'm at this I'm at the sound
booth and I went up to him and it was
doing and went from moth to the flame to
sad but true to uh like master of
puppets' and the three of us got in each
other's the to us got in each other's
faces and we acted out every song and
when we were done we had a crowd around
us and it became a tradition every night
people called me out for every song and
I remember the third leg there was about
15 of us banging her head so hard way in
the back right and all of a sudden the
song was over and it was this song and I
look up and a pic comes flying by my
head and look up its head field and he's
looking at me
shaking his head but laughing yeah
that's awesome and then after the shows
like you're in there at the
crowds your nut ball
you're a nut ball I love it that
was great
that's great but it also it shows you
man like with the you know with
the crews and with the open for
Metallica by the second night you were
like a seasoned guy in a heist movie you
like came in you go here's how it's
gonna go the car's gonna stay out front
he goes this is a three safe joint
alright we got 90 seconds when they hit
that button that's what you got 90 you
got to get in and out to call it like
that and then just to solve it
that's they don't know how many years of
comedy women well look it's gonna
because the thing is the gig kameena
clear awarding is gonna be what its
gonna be
yes I didn't walk off of any 60 shows I
did with them I've never walked off
stage one time it goes goes it's just it
was especially I said with me when I
went up there no no I was to go is the
drum tech grabbing the mic look
at this dickhead look what happens Jay
is that whole crowd looks at who is this
guy and then they look you up yeah and
then they see video like oh dude he's oh
wow and what I started seeing was the
Metallica crowd went dude he's a real
Metallica guy yeah
it really is a metallica guy well he's
really and some people started going you
know why don't you do material like dad
I'm in around yes it's eight and
by the way you're gonna talk fun no
matter what that's the thing if to rely
on that's the instinct that whatever I
do if I was talking at a funeral I just
say something funny because that's what
you know my thing is yeah and I started
going in the crowd do anything and and
the coolest thing in the world became
this is the greatest I can honestly say
it was the greatest gig I ever had in my
entire life better than TV been in film
it was the greatest gig greatest
experience ever had in my life I would I
would do it I said I would retire and do
this rest of my life but guys like you
guys like Jay only we can do this
because we can appreciate I can
appreciate what life is and these are
moments when we were kids like God if I
got to meet ball players God if I got to
hang out with the metal guys God if I
could and we I'm the Forrest Gump of
entertainment I said from day one hey I
want to work a past year I want to work
engineer all I want to do this I want to
be with Metallica I wanna and I could
sit there go yeah everything it's not
what I envisioned yeah I thought I'd
have 50 million dollars it'll be a
blockbuster star like you know why
who's gonna say I
toured with me that's crazy who's gonna
say I worked with disken who's gonna say
with a fake bat by Joe Pesci yeah it's
the great I it's the moments I said it's
the I call them the not no one can
there's there's little marks in my life
when you go don't take this away from me
you just do a thing you go that's why I
said I get but bust my balls for
bringing up how much I bring up being on
tour with Korn I'm like it's a pretty
huge moment of my life
just for me but also just in comedy I
went from like struggling and by the way
when I came off but still struggling if
I wasn't in a financial gig it was like
ya asked me if I would go on the tour
doing comedy in front of corn for 60
shows yeah Rob Zombie and I did Slipknot
and and but and then the Shiprock things
just crazy I mean it really is
it's like it but it's you're on the pole
sure when we were on the poster we both
have that poster framed from Bonnaroo we
did the comedy tent but want to post a
Billy Joel
it's a crazy crazy the beginning
of the gay porn this guy's in gay porn
[Music]
this is where we pick up the stranger at
the bus stop
yeah it's Louie stacks yeah but Bloo
drooler cuz he got the fat stacks of
dick in his pants he drills drills
chicks do drills we're doing an
overnight shift to the gas station scene
we're loose alone the only employee
there and a lady needs our car fixed
which is everybody she steals his Agnes
bar while he's taking a he comes
out catches her well there's only one
way to pay that guys already given us to
his Volvo yo guys yo top cuts if
anything in Bushwick if internet has
taught me anything to make random behind
people leave you alone
Street magic oh man this warlock
I try to get the full Scottie I don't
know if work faces microphones even
doing a God there he's the furthest away
from her you do you like your new job as
audio eight it
yeah it's true no here I'll try it
Oh how's the field we turn yeah well do
that
this feels good I think both of you guys
are doing it terribly wrong yeah I don't
get too far play for me
yeah but your arm gets tired quick dude
dude my jackass on your right I'm
standing in for Jay that's not getting
too close let's do it like we're doing
save the world
no that's sack give it back now let me
carry it for you and Jay
all right feeling just as bad a job as a
breakfast it goes right to my ear to
miss the show I'll take these headphones
right off throw that you only finish if
I smell it's really smell your mouth is
so high tiptoes
I'm trying to kiss you let's go Sam
see that guy selling that book how to
roll blunts for dummies yeah that's
awesome
hold on I'm gonna buy one I give you 20
I'll pay that
snatching grant I say snatching grab
like how the ball abacus scientists yeah
hell yeah me where today Russia
well Chardin especially need you here
it's got to work
guys awesome got to 420 yeah
you think your friends would dig this
video then share it with them and tell
them to rate and review and you know
make us feel good about ourselves you
tell a friend they tell two friends yeah
it's a pyramid scheme of a radio show
comes the whole thing I got some Cutco
knives also if you're interested
oh I got spider Cove so come to me if
you want the real one